MEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN ARCHULETA
ATKINS BATES WELL REGIS
BRADFORD CABALLERO CHIANG
DODD THEY'RE AWESOME GALGIANI
GLAZER GROWTH HERTZBERG
HELLO HUESO IT'S AUTUMN
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MITCHELL MONNING MORE LOCK
MORALE NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO
RUBIO SKINNER TURN
STONE I'M BERG WHITE
HOUSE SKI WIENER WELL
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE
WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER TODAY
BY OUR JOPLIN SYSTEM SHE
O'GORMAN AFTER WHICH I'M
GOING TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED AND
PLEDGE BY SENATOR WHITE KASKI
LET'S RELAX IN GOD'S HOLY
PRESENCE AND WE PRAY TODAY IN
THE WORDS OF EACH CUMMINGS I
THANK YOU GODS FOR MOST THIS
AMAZING DAY FOR THE LEAPING
GREENLY SPIRITS OF TREES
AND A BLUE TRUE DREAM OF SKY
AND FOR EVERYTHING WHICH IS
NATURAL WHICH IS INFINITE
WHICH IS YES I WHO HAVE DIED
I'M ALIVE AGAIN TODAY AND THIS
IS THE SON'S BIRTHDAY THIS
IS THE BIRTHDAY OF LIFE AND
OF LOVE AND WINGS AND IF THE
GAY GREATS HAPPENING A LIMIT
TO BILLY EARTH HOW SHOULD
TASTING TOUCHING HEARING SEEING
BREATHING ANY HUMAN MERELY
BEING DOUBTS ON IMAGINABLE YOU
NOW THE EARS OF MY EARS
AWAKE AND NOW THE EYES OF
MY EYES ARE OPENED AMEN
ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG OF THE UNITED
FOR WHICH IT STANDS
ONE NATION UNDER
FOR ALL
OKAY DO I SIX
OKAY MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION CYRIL FIFTY FIVE
WILL BE SUSPENDED TO ALLOW
A LOBBYIST ON THE FLOOR
FOR TODAY'S SESSION NOW
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR GROVER YOU READY NO I
SENATOR ALLEN HOW ARE YOU READY
FROM THE PROTONS DUST NO SIR
SENATOR WELCOME ARE YOU READY
TO TAKE A PER ITEM THANK YOU
CENTER WILK WHEN YOU'RE READY
FROM THIS ROAD IN THE US WHEN
YOU'RE READY SENATOR WILL
I'M SORRY I GUESS I GUESS
ARE NOT ON THE FLOOR YET
BROWN'S OKAY BECAUSE CENTER ON
COMING BACK TO YOU SENATOR
ALLEN FROM THE PRO TEM'S
DESTE WHEN YOU'RE READY
ARTS CENTER WHAT ARE YOU
READY ALL RIGHT SENATOR WILK
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IS MY PLEASURE TO
BRING TO THE SENATE FLOOR A
RESOLUTION FOR THE ASSYRIAN
NEW YEAR THIS HEARING PEOPLE
TRACE THEIR ORIGINS TO ONE
OF THE EARLIEST CIVILIZATIONS
WITH A HISTORY THAT SPANS
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND YEARS
THE SYRIAN NEW YEAR KNOWN AS
AQI TO SYMBOLIZES A TIME A
REBIRTH RENEWAL AND PROSPERITY
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST REVERED
TRADITIONS IN THE SYRIAN
HISTORY THE SYRIANS MARKED THE
CHANGE OF SEASONS WITH TWELVE
DAYS A CELEBRATION SAID IN
MODERN TIMES THIS CULMINATED
ON APRIL FIRST BY HOLDING LARGE
CELEBRATIONS FAMILY GATHERINGS
PARADES AND FESTIVALS THIS TIME
HONORED TRADITION SERVES AS
A TESTAMENT TO THE RESILIENCE
AND PERSEVERANCE OF THE
SYRIAN PEOPLE ONE THAT WILL BE
CELEBRATED FOR GENERATIONS THE
ASSYRIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
HAS BEEN AND ENCIRCLE COMPONENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA FABRIC
DATING BACK TO THE TURN OF
THE TWENTIETH CENTURY I LIKE
TO THINK THE ESSERE A SYRIAN
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE FOR SHARING
THIS WONDERFUL OCCASION WITH US
ALL IT HAS BEEN VERY MEANINGFUL
FOR FOR ME PERSONALLY TO SEE
THE GREAT WORK THEY HAVE DONE
IN MY DISTRICT WITH REGARDS
TO EDUCATION OUTREACH YOUTH
ADVOCACY AND SOCIAL SERVICES
JUST TO NAME A FEW ME THIS
UPCOMING YEAR SIX THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY NINE BE
A HEALTHY AND PROSPEROUS ONE
FOR ALL OF YOU OUR COMMUNITY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
ASSYRIAN PEOPLE WITH THIS
PROCLAMATION WE SALUTE THE SEER
-- SYRIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
ACROSS CALIFORNIA FOR ITS
RESILIENCE AND VIBRANT SEES
WITH ME TODAY I'D LIKE TO --
PUBLICLY RECOGNIZED PETER WARDA
ROM ON TOSH AND JOHN CORIO
FROM THE ASSYRIAN AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS OF THE
SYRIAN COMMUNITY FROM AROUND
THE STATE UP IN THE GALLERY
INCLUDING THE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE SYRIAN AMERICAN
SAID THE CLUB OF TURLOCK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
THANK YOU SENATOR WOKE
AND WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
SENATOR ALLEN ARE YOU
READY FOR S. C. R.
THIRTY THREE IF SO WHEN YOU'RE
READY FROM THE PRO TEM SUGGEST
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY THREE BY SENATOR ALLEN
RELATIVE TO ARTS CULTURE AND
CREATIVITY MONTH.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
MEMBERS I SAW THIS -- ESSIE OUR
THIRTY THREE DESIGNATES APRIL.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND EVERY APRIL
THERE AFTER AS ARTS CULTURE AND
CREATIVITY MONTH.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE ARTS -- GIVE.
SPRING FROM AND AND GIVE VOICE
TO CALIFORNIA'S MANY DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES SPARKING CREATIVITY
FOSTER EMPATHY AND UNDERSTANDING
SPURRING.
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT CALIFORNIA
PLEASE -- HIGHER NUMBER OF
CALVET PEOPLE THE ARTS AND
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES INCLUDING
ENTERTAINMENT ARCHITECTURE.
FASHION MEDIA AND PUBLISHING THE
GOLDEN STATE OF COURSE IS THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD -- BUT EVERYONE ALSO KNOWS
THAT THE ARE SECRETIVE
INDUSTRIES.
ARE A CRITICAL PART OF WHAT
MAKES CALIFORNIA SO SPECIAL --
THESE INDUSTRIES ACCOUNT FROM
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ALONE.
OUR STATE AND COUNTRY ARE IN THE
MIDST OF A CHALLENGING --
SITUATION BY WHERE WHERE MANY
DIFFERENT VOICES DOMINATE
PERHAPS TOO MUCH OF THE PUBLIC
DEBATE.
ABOUT THIS IS A MOMENT FOR US TO
NOT FORGET THAT ART IS PROVEN
TIME AND TIME AGAIN THAT IT HAS
THE INHERENT POWER NOT ONLY DO
INSPIRE.
BUT ALSO TO BRING US CLOSER
TOGETHER SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE ESSIE OUR THIRTY THREE
CELEBRATING CONFIRM OUR
COMMITMENT IN SUPPORT OF ARTS.
CULTURE AND CREATIVITY ACROSS
THE STATE.
THANK YOU.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN BY HI ARCHIE LETTER.
HI ATKINS.
BY BATES.
AYE BELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DON.
I THEIR OSEM.
HI GALGIANI.
WELL MY GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
HI JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LUCK [inaudible]
I MORRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I CAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I BROUGHT [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
HI WILK [inaudible]
HI.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT
TO MEMBERS [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
HI.
ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES.
CENTER ALLEN.
FOR MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THAT
IMPORTANT RESOLUTION WE HAVE
SOME FOLKS HERE WHO ARE -- FROM
THE NATIONAL CONFERENCE OF STATE
LEGISLATURES AND ALSO AMERICANS
FOR THE ARTS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INTRODUCE THEM HERE TODAY -- MR
J. DICK AND ALSO MISS NANCY RIME --
JAY'S A SENIOR DIRECTOR OF STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR
AMERICANS FOR THE ARTS FOLKS MAY
KNOW THAT THE ORGANIZATION WAS
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN SIXTY IT'S
THE LEADING NONPROFIT.
ORGANIZATION FOR ADVANCING THE
ARTS AND ARTS EDUCATION IN OUR
COUNTRY.
JAY IS A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
SPEAKER ON ARTS POLICY HE WORKS
TO EDUCATE INFORM AND BUILD
PUBLIC.
TRUST AND WILL IN THE
TRANSFORMATIVE VALUE OF THE ARTS
THROUGH COALITION BUILDING WITH
OTHER KEY ORGANIZATIONS ON STATE.
LOCAL AND NATIONAL LEVELS NANCY
RIME HIGHS DEBBIE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL COVER TO STATE
LEGISLATURES AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THE NCSL FOUNDATION FOR STATE
LEGISLATURES AND SHE'S WORKED.
WITH THE LEGISLATURE'S ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY -- FROM FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS IS YOU KNOW
IT'S AN ORGANIZATION THAT BRINGS
TOGETHER.
OUR OUR SISTERS AND BROTHERS
FROM OTHER STATE LEGISLATURES
AND AND IF HE'S WORKED
PARTICULARLY ON ON ISSUES OF THE
V. ARTS.
NCSL IN AMERICANS FOR THE ARTS
WORK TOGETHER BY CONVENING
POLICY EVENTS FOR THEIR MEMBERS
ON ARTS AND CULTURE.
PRODUCING ARTS IMPACTS CITIES
WHICH PROVIDE USEFUL DATA TO
STATE LEGISLATURES IN ADVANCE
ARTS EDUCATION AND THERAPEUTIC
ARTS PROGRAMS FOR OUR VETERANS
AND I AM PARTICULARLY PROUD OF
ALL OF THE WORK THEY DO HELPING
VETERANS WHO COME HOME FROM --
FROM MORE WHO ARE SUFFERING FROM
PTSD AND ENGAGING THEM IN ARTS
THERAPY IN A WAY THAT CAN REALLY
BE TRANSFORMATIVE SO I WANT TO
THANK THE TWO OF THEM FOR
HELPING. TO LEAD THE FIGHT TO
BUILD MORE VIBRANT COMMUNITIES
TO THE ARTS DEVELOPINGSOUND
ARTS POLICIES AROUND OUR COUNTRY.
I THAT WE CAN TURN TO HERE AT
OUR STATE WHERE AN ESTIMATED ONE
IN TEN JOBS ARE LINKED TO THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY AND SO FOR
THEIR ADVOCACY AND FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP IN THE ARTS.
IN OUR SEEN THROUGHOUT THE
NATION I ASK MY COLLEAGUES TO
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING JAY AND
THAT'S THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
RECEPTION IS EVEN IF YOU'RE JUST.
PLEASE -- PLEASE REACH OUT TO ME
WE'LL LET YOU KNOW ABOUT IT BUT
I'VE EVEN WARM WARM SENATE
WALKING THE CHANCES.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
HILL ARE YOU READY.
I AM MR PRESIDENT FROM THE PRO
TEM SUGGEST.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT TODAY
I RISE. TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK
A DEDICATED.
LONG TIME MEMBER OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE STAFF NATE SOLO.
WHO HAS BEEN MY CHIEF OF STAFF
TO THE INTHE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND?
EIGHT IT IS A BITTERSWEET DAY
FOR ME THE MEMBERS OF MY OFFICE
IN MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE WHO HAVE HAD THE
GREAT OPPORTUNITY. TO WORK WITH
NATE OVER THE PAST EIGHTEEN
YEARS.
EVERY LEGISLATURE HOPE LET EVERY
LEGISLATOR HOPES.
HOPES TO HAVE A CHIEF OF STAFF.
WHO NOT ONLY SHARES HIS OR HER
VISION?
BUT ALSO HE HAS THE SKILLS THE
KNOWLEDGE AND THE WISDOM TO MAKE
THAT VISION A REALITY. TO EXTEND
IT TO NEW HORIZONS.
AND ALL THE WHILE HAVE YOUR BACK.
IN THE PAST ELEVEN YEARS IT IS
WORK CLOSELY WITH ME ON AN
INTENSE LEGISLATIVE PORTFOLIO ON
ISSUES OF PATIENT SAFETY
INCREASED ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
DOCTORS CONTRACTORS.
IN A RANGE OF OTHER PROFESSIONS
AS WELL AS PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE
COASTAL JIM THAT IS MARTIN'S
BEACH AND MUCH MORE MUCH MUCH
MORE HE HAS BEEN MY RIGHT.
ARM.
HIS TALENTS IT IS THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY DEGREE VISION ARE
WOULD HAVE MADE NATE SUCH A
PHENOMENAL SUCH A PHENOMENAL
CHIEF OF STAFF.
THEY ARE WHAT MAKE HIM AN
INVALUABLE ADDITION TO ANY
ORGANIZATION HE JOINS THERE
WOULD GIVE HIM THE GREAT
CONFIDENCE AND GIVE ME THE GREAT
CONFIDENCE THAT THE TEAM HAS.
HE HAS HELPED ME A SYMBOL WILL
GO FORWARD WITHOUT MISSING A
STEP BECAUSE IN ADDITION TO BE
AN OUTSTANDING TEAM PLAYER AND
IT IS ALSO AN EXCEPTIONAL TEAM
LEADER.
HE FOSTERS LEADERSHIP AND
COHESION AMONG THOSE HE WORKS
WITH.
WITH HIS HELP WE HAVE BUILT AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS MORE THAN A
STAFF.
IN EVEN MORE THAN A TEAM WE ARE
A FAMILY.
AND I KNOW THAT EVERYONE WHO HAS
WORKED WITH NAY FEELS THE SAME.
GROWTH AND CHANGE ARE PART OF
ALL FAMILIES.
WELL WE SAY GOODBYE AND GOOD
LUCK TO YOU TODAY NAY.
WE KNOW WE WILL SEE MORE OF YOU
IN THE FUTURE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE NEXT
TIME THAT WE GET TOGETHER.
HAPPY THAT NAY EACH YEAR JOINED
BY HIS WONDERFUL WIFE KELLY.
THEY'RE WONDERFUL CHILDREN ARE A
POLICE.
AND HOT HANNAH RIGHT HERE.
AND THE MOTHER AND DAD JOANNE
AND MARTY SELLOFF IN NAY SISTER
AMY IS HERE AS WELL SO.
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FOR THE NAY FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
.
SENATOR GROVE WHEN YOU'RE READY.
FROM THE PRO TEM'S DESTE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
SPECIAL GUEST.
I'M HONORED TO IN ORDER TO GROW
THIS WAIT LET'S YES ON THE HOUSE
A LITTLE BIT YES SIR OKAY --
CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT IN
AND SPECIAL GUEST I MINORED IN
INTRODUCED A GROUP OF WONDERFUL
COMMUNITY LEADERS WHO ARE HERE
CELEBRATING.
THE U. GALL THE FESTIVAL MEMBERS
OF THE SILICON ANDHRA AND THE
TELUGU ASSOCIATION OF GREATER
SACRAMENTO HAVE BEEN CELEBRATING
THE FESTIVAL WHICH IS THE LUNAR
NEW YEAR'S DAY FOR TELUGU
COMMUNITIES.
THE CELEBRATION ALSO MARKS AN
ARRIVAL OF SPRING AND WARMER
WEATHER IN A JOYOUS FESTIVAL
FESTIVAL SIGNIFYING -- NEW
GROWTH AND NEW PROSPERITY.
AND WITH ALL THE NEW YEAR'S
FESTIVITIES AND FESTIVALS THAT
ARE YOU KNOW USUALLY THAT WE DO
CELEBRATE IT'S A GREAT CHANCE TO
PUT OUR PROBLEMS BEHIND US.
IN A PASSED IN OUR PAST BEHIND
US AND AN OPPORTUNITY FOR NEW
VENTURES AND FRESH BEGINNINGS
THIS YEAR OUR FRIENDS STARTED
THE CELEBRATION OF THE U. GALL
THE FESTIVAL.
ON APRIL SIXTH AND IT CONTINUES
FOR NINE DAYS WE WANT TO THANK
THE MEMBERS OF THE SILICON
ANDHRA.
IN THE TELUGU ASSOCIATION OF
GREATER SACRAMENTO TO BE HERE AT
THE STATE CAPITOL TODAY AT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THEM IN MY
OFFICE AND TAKE PHOTOS AND ALSO
SENATOR HERTZBERG WAS ABLE TO
JOIN US SO THAT.
HE COULD TAKE PHOTOS WITH THEM
AS WELL AND MEET WITH THEM
THEY'VE SHOWN EXEMPLARY
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
OUTSTANDING SERVICE TO OUR
COMMUNITY BY PROMOTING THE
INDIAN CULTURE AND A GROWING
INNING AND ENCOURAGING GROW
THROUGH ACTUALLY FROM -- TELL
WHO IS FROM THE SOUTHEAST PART
OF INDIA.
SO TELL AGREE WELL LINE DIE
REEKIE SAYS HAPPY NEW YEAR SO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING OUR
HONORED GUESTS THAT ARE WITH US
TODAY.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE AND HAPPY NEW YEAR
.
SENATOR BILL ARE YOU READY FOR
YOUR ITEM.
WHEN YOU'RE READY?
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO I'M.
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING THE
NATIONAL LINES ON MENTAL ILLNESS.
CALIFORNIA ON THEIR FORTIETH
ANNIVERSARY.
NOW MAY HAS SPENT THE LAST FORTY
YEARS BRAIN AWARENESS AND
ATTENTION. TO MENTAL HEALTH
MOVING COMMUNITIES TO SUPPORT
MENTAL HEALTH WELLNESS THROUGH
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT OPTIONS
ADVOCATING FOR PROVIDING OPEN
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT AND SERVICES -- NAOMI
WAS FOUNDED.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE BY A
FEW COURAGEOUS PARENT LEADERS
MANY FAMILIES AND THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS FRIENDS AND
PROFESSIONALS WHO WORK
DILIGENTLY. TO GIVE BIRTH TO THE
ORGANIZATION.
THAT WOULD COMPLETELY CHANGE THE
WAY MENTAL ILLNESSES VIEWED.
IT'S A GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS
OF FAMILIES INDIVIDUALS WHO
LIVES HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY.
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS SENATE
BILL ONE MINUTE WE'RE GONNA TRY
TO QUIET THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS WERE YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER A PRESIDENT --%
SO THESE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS WORKING TO PROVIDE HELP
HOPE.
AND HEALING -- FOR THEIR
FAMILIES THEY WORK TO PROVIDE A
STRONG COHERENT SYSTEM.
THAT OFFERS A CONTINUUM OF CARE
FOR THE PRESIDENT LONG TERM
NEEDS OF PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS THAT NOW ME ALSO
ADVOCATES FOR INCREASED RESEARCH.
DON COVER CAUSES IN NEW
EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS AND STRIVES
TO CREATE A RADIC KATE.
DISCRIMINATION.
OF THOSE WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
TODAY THE ORGANIZATION SERVICES
THE STATE'S VOICE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS AND IS DEDICATED TO
BUILDING BETTER LIVES. FOR
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS AND AND
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
AFFECTED BY MAIL ON US.
WE LIKE TO GIVE A BIG WARM
WELCOME TO NAM IN CELEBRATION OF
THEIR FORTIETH ANNIVERSARY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
YES SIR TODAY OR JESSICA CREWS
SHE'S THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AND STEEP HI.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL.
I HOPE YOU HAVE YOUR GREEN
RIBBON ONTO
.
MEMBERS NOW WOULD ASK YOU TO
DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION TO THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER WE HAVE TWO
SPECIAL GUESTS THAT WE LOVE TO
RECOGNIZE AT THIS POINT.
WE HAVE DAVID SOLO PRESIDENT AND
CEO SPECIAL OLYMPICS FOR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA.
AND A SPECIAL ATHLETE DAVID
PLUNKETT ATHLETE AND PUBLIC
SPEAKER WOULD YOU PLEASE STAND
TO BE RECOGNIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
SENATOR MITCHELL FOR WHAT
PURPOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
READY.
MEMBERS AS A LETTER AT THE DESK
REQUESTING WITHDRAWAL OF THE
FOLLOWING SENATE BILLS FROM THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE AND OR THE BILL TO
SECOND READING THE BILLS ARE.
SB SEVENTY FOUR THROUGH.
858-729-8100 TO ONE HUNDRED
NINETEEN A HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
THROUGH ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR GROW [inaudible]
REMARKS ON THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I'M I WOULD LIKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THIS ROUTE ON
THIS MOTION AND I WOULD ALSO
LIKE MY MEMBERS TO VOTE NO ON
THIS.
WITHDRAW.
MEMBERS THE MOTION REQUIRES
TWENTY ONE VOTES TO KERRY
SENATOR MITCH WAS ASKING FOR AYE
VOTE SENATOR GROVE IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS.
HI BATES [inaudible]
NO WELL [inaudible]
HI GORGEOUS.
NO BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD.
HI THERE I WAS A GALGIANI
[inaudible]
HI GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HI HILL [inaudible]
HI HUESO.
BY -- THOUGHT OF HI JACKSON
[inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN [inaudible]
HI PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER [inaudible]
HI STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
HI WHITE HOUSE STATE
[inaudible]
HI WIENER [inaudible]
I WELL.
NO.
MA'AM SURGERY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS ARCHULETA.
HI THE RISE OF HI.
ICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS.
TEN THE MOTION CARRIES.
NEXT ITEM MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR.
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGE FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
DR.
NEXT CONSIDERATION DAILY FILE
[inaudible]
SECOND READING.
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH.
TEN SECRETARY PLESE RATE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS TO A SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS TO EIGHTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS THREE SIXTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS. THREE SIXTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS ONE SIXTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS SECOND READING WILL
BE DEEMED READ.
NEXT UP GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
SIR WHAT ARE YOU READY -- YES
MISTER PRESIDENT.
AT THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
IS A CONFIRMATION OF WEIGHT
CROWFOOT AS SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY.
MR CROWFOOT WAS A CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT THE WATER
FOUNDATION.
AND PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS A
DEPUTY CABINET SECRETARY AND
SENIOR ADVISER TO GOVERNOR BROWN
IS A BREATH OF EXPERIENCE ALSO
INCLUDES LEADING CLIMATE
PROTECTION INITIATIVES.
IN SAN FRANCISCO FOR THEN MAYOR
NEWSOM.
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MARCH TWENTIETH ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
HERTZBERG UNDER THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU RICH ON THE SIDE IN
THE MISTER PRESIDENT I NORMALLY
DON'T STAND ON THESE THINGS BUT
I JUST GOTTA STAND AND AND AND
PROVIDE MY WHOLE HEARTED SUPPORT
FOR MISTER CROW FOR I WORK WITH
THEM WHEN I SERVED IN.
SURE OF NATURAL RESOURCES IN
WATER AND TRAVEL AROUND THE
STATE TO SALTON SEA IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE AND HE'S JUST
AN EXTRAORDINARY PUBLIC SERVANT.
AND I'M JUST PROUD THAT -- WE'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO NOMINATE
THE GOVERNOR NOMINATE HIM AND
ASK YOU FOR SUPPORT [inaudible]
SENATOR NELSON.
SPECIALIZED IN DOWN THE SENATE
I'D LIKE TO LEND MY VOICE
SUPPORT FOR OF WADE CROWFOOT
THAT I'VE MET WITH HIM ON
RESOURCE ISSUES AND THAT NO OF
HIS HISTORY.
I FIND IT TO BE A VERY
RESPONSIVE AND RESPONSIBLE
INDIVIDUAL I THINK YOU WILL BE A
GOOD STEWARD OF OUR RESOURCES
AND SERVICE STATE IN GOOD ORDER
I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SEEN ANY.
NO FURTHER.
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR WHAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON THE
APPOINTMENT.
I GET ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU BOB SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL CALL ON THE POINT
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
HI BATES [inaudible]
I FELT [inaudible]
HI GORGEOUS.
I BRADFORD.
HI HOW THEY HAD A HI CHIANG
[inaudible]
HI DODD.
HI THERE I WAS A HI GALGIANI
[inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
PINE GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HI HILL.
HI HUESO.
I HER TODD OF JACKSON
[inaudible]
HI JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
HI MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL.
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HI GROUND.
I NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
HI ROUGH [inaudible]
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I AMBERG.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
HI WIENER.
I WELL.
HI.
I'M SURGERY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS.
GROWTH [inaudible]
HI -- TADA.
I JONES OR HI.
ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
EXCEPT MEMBERS THE SENATE THIRD
READING ITEMS.
THIRTEEN TO TWENTY THREE THERMAL
BAR ARE YOU READY.
SENATE MCGUIRE FROM YOUR DESTINY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA WINDS
DOWN TO EARTH MONTH [inaudible]
SENATE MCGUIRE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR PRESIDENT
THANKS FOR YOUR HARD WORK SIR
I'M HAPPY PRISON ESSIE OUR
TWENTY THREE WITH THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM NAPA.
WHICH PROCLAIMS THE MONTH OF
APRIL IS CALIFORNIA WINES DOWN
TO EARTH MONTH THIS MONTH
CELEBRATES THIS IS STABLE
LEADERSHIP OF CALIFORNIA
WINERIES IN THOUSANDS OF WINE
GRAPE GROWERS.
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA MAKES UP 81%
OF ALL AMERICAN WINE WITH FORTY
NINE OUT OF THE IFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN THE GOLDEN STATE
GROWING WINE GRAPES IN THE
INDUSTRY GENERATES OVER THIRTY
THREE INTERNET. TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND JOBS AND THAT CONTINUES
TO GROW SUSTAINABILITY IS A
VITAL PART OF THE GOLDEN STATE'S
WINE INDUSTRY AND THAT'S WHY IT
CONTINUES TO THRIVE. 70% 70%
MISTER PRESIDENT OF ALL WINE
GRAPES GROWN IN CALIFORNIA ARE
AND ROLLED IN THE SUSTAINABILITY
PROGRAM IN WINERIES THAT PRODUCE
80% OF CALIFORNIA WINE ARE
PROBABLY PARTICIPATING AS WELL.
CALIFORNIA WINE STANDARDS MONTH
IS MORE THAN A NAME OF JUST ONE
MONTH IT'S A MISSION OF THIS
INDUSTRY AND IS ADOPTED
SUSTAINABILITY THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS A YEAR MISTER
PRESIDENT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DINNER CABALLERO.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF S.
C. R. TWENTY THREE WHICH
CELEBRATES CALIFORNIA WINES AND
THE SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES IN
WHICH CALIFORNIA WINES ARE GROWN
AND PRODUCED.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FOURTH LARGEST
WINE PRODUCING REGION IN THE
WORLD BEHIND FRANCE ITALY AND
SPAIN AND FRANKLY.
WE PRODUCE SOME OF THE BEST.
WIND DEFINES A CALIFORNIA WAY OF
LIFE IN MY DISTRICT WINE IS
BECOME A LARGE PART OF THE
ECONOMY AND THE CULTURE.
WHETHER IN THE SALINAS VALLEY
SAN BENITO COUNTY OR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FARMERS ARE MAKING AND
ENJOYING WINE.
PROVIDED TRAVEL DESTINATION THAT
ENCOURAGES TOURISM AND ECONOMIC
VITALITY IN HER.
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA.
THE WINE INDUSTRY IS ALSO A
LEADER IN SUSTAINABLE FARMING
PRACTICES AND IS AN INDUSTRY
DESERVING OF RECOGNITION FOR ITS.
RESPONSIBLE ECOLOGICAL
STEWARDSHIP OF THE LAND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
RESOLUTION AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR DODD.
THIS PRESIDENT MEMBERS I STAND
AS SPROUT CO AUTHOR OF BESSIE
ARE TWENTY THREE WHICH
CELEBRATES APRIL WAS CALIFORNIA
WINES.
DOWN TO EARTH MONTH EVERY YEAR
THE MONTH OF APRIL CALIPH IN
CALIFORNIA WIDE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE FOCUS ON GREEN
PRACTICES DURING THE CALIFORNIA.
WIVES DOWN TO EARTH MONTH
CELEBRATION WINE BENEFITS NOT
JUST MY DISTRICT BUT ALL OF
CALIFORNIA IT ADDS BILLIONS TO
THE ECONOMY.
THOUSANDS OF JOBS AND BOOST
TOURISM I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR --
SEEING FURTHER THE SENATOR
NELSON.
THIS PRESENT LAYS DOWN WITH THE
SENATE THE WINE INDUSTRY IS
GENERAL IN THE AGRICULTURAL
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA.
I REMEMBER THE STUDIES OF
HISTORY AND BY THE SIERRA THE
MISSION WINDS THAT BECAME.
SO WELL IN CHARGE HERE.
AND THEN OVER THE THOUSANDS OF
DECK OR YEARS IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR WINDS HAVE BEEN RECOGNIZED.
I USED TO HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
REPRESENTING NAPA SONOMA.
SENATOR DODD NOW HAS AT
PRIVILEGE BUT A LOT OF THE AREAS
THAT I DO REPRESENT EVEN NOW.
IN THE EASTERN SIERRAS DO GROW
SOME MOUNTAIN WINDS.
AND AGAIN CALIFORNIA HAS LONG
BEEN RECOGNIZED AND I'M -- PROUD
TO ANNOUNCE THAT -- STAG'S LEAP
WINERY IS GONNA APPROACHES
FORTIETH YEAR THIS YEAR.
OF WINNING THE WINE COMPETITION
THE PARIS BLIND TASTING.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THAT.
AFTER EIGHTY SEVENTY FOUR WHERE
THEY PAYMENT NUMBER.
ONE A CALIFORNIA CHARDONNAY FROM
SONOMA COUNTY [inaudible]
IN A THE THE THE CHARDONNAY.
FROM OF ALSO FROM THE SONOMA
COUNTY. ONE AND BORN WITH OUR
SKIS RED.
WAS A NUMBER ONE THAT A STAG'S
LEAP WINERY.
WE HAVE A GREAT HISTORY AND SOME
OF THE PIONEERS OF THE WINE
INDUSTRY SUCH AS THE GALLOWS
[inaudible]
ROBERT MONDAVI.
MANY OTHERS HAVE HELPED PUT
CALIFORNIA WINES ON THE WORLD
MAP.
WE ARE RESPECTED WE ARE GREAT WE
ARE KNOWN FOR THOSE LINES AND
INDEED AS STEWARDS OF THE LAND.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SIR MCGUIRE.
YOU CAN CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT GRATEFUL FOR ALL THE
MEMBERS STANDING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION TODAY WE TOAST
CALIFORNIA WINE WITH ESSIE OUR
TWENTY THREE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION FOR FOR USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE
OF SEEING HEARING ON MEASURE
PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NEXT UP IS
ITEM.
FOURTEEN BY CENTER HERTZBERG.
CENTER HERTZBERG ARE YOU READY
READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL.
ME PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHT BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
RELATIVE TO THE STATE CAPITOL
BUILDING.
CENTERS FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE EACH DAY.
WE HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO WALK
INTO THESE CHAMBERS.
AND TO DO THE PEOPLE'S WORK.
BUT WE DON'T OFTEN THINK ABOUT.
WHO WERE THE FIRST TO SIT HERE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS AGO?
BUT TAKE A MOMENT TO PAUSE AND
THINK ABOUT THAT.
IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY YEARS AGO OUR PREDECESSORS
SAT IN THIS ROOM. FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
WHAT CALIFORNIA IS ADMITTED AS
THE THIRTY FIRST STATE INTO THE
UNION IN?
EIGHTEEN FIFTY IT WASN'T UNTIL
EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE VOTED TO MAKE
SACRAMENTO THE PERMANENT HOME OF
THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
IN THAT TIME IN BETWEEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CAPITOL WAS
LOCATED IN VARIOUS CITIES.
INCLUDING SAN JOSE AND OUR OWN
FIFTEENTH SENATORIAL DISTRICT.
AND BOTH BENICIA AND VALLEJO
BOTH IN THE THIRD SENATORIAL
DISTRICT.
AT EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR
SACRAMENTO OFFICIALLY BECAME THE
SEAT OF OUR STATE GOVERNMENT.
AT EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE THIS BILL
BUILDING.
MEMBERS BECAME OUR HOME.
IT WAS HERE IN THIS BUILDING
THAT THE ORIGINAL FOR CODES OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WERE
WRITTEN IN.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO THE CIVIL
CODE CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE THE
PENAL CODE.
AND THE POLITICAL COAT.
IN NINETEEN ELEVEN IT WAS HERE
IN THIS BUILDING THAT WE CREATED
THE RIGHTS OF CITIZENS REPOSE
BALLOT INITIATIVES IT WAS HERE
AT THAT TIME IN THIS BUILDING
THAT WE ESTABLISH THE EIGHT HOUR
WORK DAY.
AND WORKERS COMP IT WAS HERE IN
THIS BUILDING AT THAT TIME THAT
WE BECAME THE SIX STATE.
GIVE WOMEN'S THE RIGHT WOMEN THE
RIGHT TO VOTE IN.
NINETEEN ELEVEN AND IN NINETEEN
FORTY SIX IT WAS HERE IN THIS
BUILDING THAT WE REPEALED
SEGREGATION IN SCHOOLS. TWENTY
YEARS BEFORE THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT IT WAS HERE IN THIS
BUILDING THAT WE PASS FAIR
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES IN NINETEEN
FIFTY NINE YEARS BEFORE THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT.
OF NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR PASSED BY
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS AND
IT WAS HERE IN THIS BUILDING
THAT WE ADOPTED THE WATER
QUALITY CONTROL ACT IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BEFORE THE
ADVOCATE WHICH BECAME A
BLUEPRINT FOR THE FEDERAL CLEAN
WATER ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO SIGNED INTO LAW BY PRESIDENT
NIXON.
AND IT WAS HERE IN THIS BUILDING
WHERE THE FIRST WE WERE THE
FIRST STATE TO ESTABLISH
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS AND BEGAN
A LONG HISTORY OF EXPANDING THE
RIGHTS TO THE LGBT COMMUNITY.
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE IN
PREPARING FOR HIS RESOLUTION WE
FOUND THE REMARKS IN PREPARING
FOR THIS RESOLUTION WE FOUND THE
MARKS OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
WILLIAM HOLDEN.
WHO HERE ON DECEMBER SIXTH
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE CONVENE THE
LEGISLATURE IN THESE CHAMBERS
FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME?
ON THAT DATE WHEN THE CLOCK
STRUCK NOON HE CALLED THE SENATE
TO ORDER TO ADDRESS THE SENATORS.
AND HE SAID.
AMONG OTHER THINGS.
LET US SEE TO IT.
THAT THE LABOR OF THOSE WHO
REARED THESE MASSIVE WALLS.
AS WELL AS THE ARTISTIC SKILLS
WHICH ADORN THESE BEAUTIFUL
HALLS SHALL BE FULLY COMPENSATED.
IF THE LAWS YOU SHOW FRAME
DURING THIS SESSION SHALL HAVE
THE SAME SOLIDARITY THE SAME
ELEGANCE A PROPORTION.
THE END OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS MAY
WELL SAY.
WELL DONE GOOD AND FAITHFUL
SERVICE.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT WAS SO LONG
AGO CERTAINLY A GREAT DEAL OF
TIME HAS PASSED SINCE THAT DAY.
BUT AS YOU THINK ABOUT IT FOR A
MOMENT IT WAS ONLY FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED DAYS.
WE SPENT FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN A BLINK.
WHEN WILLIAM HOLDEN SAID THOSE
WORDS?
BUT FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND DAYS
HASN'T CHANGE WHAT WE GATHER
HERE TO DO WE GATHER HERE TO
MEET THE CHALLENGES OF HOW
BETTER. TO BETTER OUR HUMAN
CONDITIONS IN OUR SOCIETY.
BUT OUR CHARGE IS NOT CHANGED
BUT CERTAINLY OUR SOCIETY HAS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO.
IN EIGHTEEN NINETY THREE ALL OF
SOCIETY'S GREATEST MINDS
GATHERED CHICAGO'S WORLD THERE.
AND THEY WERE ASKED TO PREDICT
WHAT GREAT INVENTIONS WOULD COME
IN THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS.
NOT A SINGLE ONE OF THEM
PREDICTED THE AUTOMOBILE.
SO AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
NEXT HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS OR
MAYBE EVEN THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS.
WE WILL BE DEALING WITH ISSUES
OF DRIVERLESS CARS IN THE CHANGE
THE NATURE OF WORK IN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND HOW TECH HOW
STUDENTS LEARN AND SO MANY OTHER
CHALLENGES THAT WE WILL MEET.
WITH THE SAME VIGOR AND
INTELLIGENCE AND RIGOR THAT WE
HAVE IN TERMS OF MEETING THE
CHALLENGES OF CHANGES SOCIETY
OVER THE YEARS.
WITH HARD WORK MEMBERS THE
SISTINE BODY WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND LET'S TAKE
A MOMENT TODAY.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS RESOLUTION
TO COMMEMORATE THE HUNDRED AND
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S LEGISLATURE'S
PERMANENT HOME HERE IN
SACRAMENTO MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOAT
[inaudible]
CENTER MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
SIGNIFICANT MILESTONES ARE
IMPORTANT TO COMMEMORATE AND THE
SESQUI CENTENNIAL.
OF THESE FOLLOWED.
HOLES THIS CAPITAL IS ONE WE
SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE.
GOLD WAS DISCOVERED IN EIGHTEEN
FORTY EIGHT WE BECAME A STATE IN.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY THE CAPITAL
SELECTION WAS.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR THE FIRST
CONVENING WAS EIGHTEEN SIXTY
NINE IN THIS CAPITAL WAS
FINISHED IT FULLY COMPLETED IN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FOUR POP POP
POP POP.
JUST AN INCREDIBLE [inaudible]
BEGINNING.
I APPLAUD THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
LA. FOR INTRODUCING THIS
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZING THE
HUNDRED FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S FIRST
COMMUTING SESSION IN THIS
GLORIOUS CATHEDRAL.
OUR MUTUAL FRIEND NOW DECEASED
FORMER STATE LIBRARIAN KEVIN
STARR.
WOULD BE PLEASED.
HE WORKED DILIGENTLY ON SOME
FORM OF ACKNOWLEDGMENT AND
COMMEMORATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
HUNDRED AND FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE DISCOVERY OF GOLD TO
STATEHOOD FROM NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT TO TWO THOUSAND AND I
WOULD RECOMMEND HIS BOOK SERIES.
CALIFORNIA DREAM.
ON OCCASION I'LL SEE AN OLDER
VEHICLE WITHOUT A LICENSE PLATE
FRAME.
THAT SHOWS ON THE BOTTOM OF THE
WHITE PLATE SESQUI CENTENNIAL
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS.
IF I AM FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
STILL BE IN THE LEGISLATURE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR I HOPE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS TASK WAS
CENTENNIAL OF THE COMPLETION.
OF THIS MAGNIFICENT CAPITOL
BUILDING.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
AN S. C. R. EIGHT AND COMMEND.
THE HISTORY LEADING SENATOR.
THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER FOR
HIS DILIGENCE TO THE DETAILS OF
CALIFORNIA'S INFANCY SHE HAS
GONE VERY FAR.
IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN.
I THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
CENTERS I JUST WANT TO THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRING THIS RESOLUTION FORD AND
REMINDING US OF THE TREMENDOUS
HISTORY THAT'S OCCURRED IN THIS
CHAMBER THAT WE SIT IN --
REGULARLY AND AGAIN -- THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGS RESOLUTION
FOR DINNER TONIGHT THANK YOU.
SEEN.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM SENATOR.
HERTZBERG WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE
THANK YOU AS I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE I JUST WANT
TO REMIND THE MEMBERS I THINK
THEY'VE GOTTEN NOTICE IN YOUR
OFFICE.
THAT THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND I INVITE YOU TO JOIN
US FOR A SHORT RECEPTION TO SEE
THE NEW EXHIBIT ROOMS FOR THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY AT THE
RECEPTION KICKS OFF TONIGHT FROM
FOUR THIRTY TO FIVE THIRTY ON
THE FIRST FLOOR THE HISTORIC
SIDE OF THE BUILDING.
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU.
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION OF USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE.
SENATE HEARING ON THE MEASURE
PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NEXT UP ITEM
FIFTEEN A C. R. NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN CENTER DELAY OF ARE YOU
READY I AM READY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR LEYVA
RELATIVE TO ORGAN AND TISSUE
DONATION.
CENTER LEYVA THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY IS A PROUD AUTHOR
OF S. C. OR TWENTY SEVEN WHICH
PROCLAIMS APRIL TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AS DONATE LIFE.
DMV PARTNERSHIP MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
DONATE LIKE CALIFORNIA IS
CHARGED WITH EDUCATING THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THE NEED AND
IMPORTANCE FOR PEOPLE TO
REGISTER THEIR DONATION WISHES.
IN APRIL TWO THOUSAND FIVE
CALIFORNIA LOST LAUNCH THE FIRST
EVER DONOR REGISTRY IN THE STATE
CALLED THE DONATE LIFE
CALIFORNIA ORGAN AND TISSUE
DONOR REGISTRY.
THIS DATABASE ALLOWS
CALIFORNIANS TO SHARE THEIR
ORGAN AND TISSUE DONATION WISHES
BY REGISTERING ONLINE.
REGISTERED ORGAN EYE AND TISSUE
DONORS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE SAVE
NEARLY SEVEN THOUSAND LIVES AND
HELP HEAL AN ESTIMATED SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE PEOPLE
SINCE DONATE LIFE CALIFORNIA AND
THE DMV BECAME OFFICIAL PARTNERS.
TEN YEARS AGO.
AS OF TODAY DONATE LIFE
CALIFORNIA'S SUCCESSFULLY ADDED
OVER. FIFTEEN MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE TO THE
REGISTRY HOWEVER NEARLY A
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN THOUSAND
AMERICANS ARE CURRENTLY WAITING
FOR AN ORGAN TRANSPLANT WITH
NEARLY TWENTY TWO OF THOSE
THOUSAND OF THOSE LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA.
ON AVERAGE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PEOPLE WERE ADDED TO THE
NATION'S ORGAN TRANSPLANT.
TRANSPLANT LIST EACH DAY IN FACT
A NEW PERSON IS ADDED TO THE
LIST EVERY TEN MINUTES.
CURRENTLY AN AVERAGE OF TWENTY
TWO PATIENTS DIE EVERY DAY WHILE
WAITING SIMPLY BECAUSE AN ORGAN
THEY NEED WAS EITHER UNAVAILABLE
OR NOT DONATED IN TIME.
ESSERE TWENTY SEVEN WILL HELP TO
ADDRESSES DONOR SHORTAGE BY
BRING AWARENESS TO MANY TO THE
MANY OPPORTUNITIES CALIFORNIANS
HAVE TO SIGN ON TO THE OFFICIAL
STATE ORGAN EYE AND TISSUE DONOR
REGISTRY.
BY DECLARING APRIL TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AS DONATE LIFE THE MV
PARTNERSHIP MONTH IN CALIFORNIA
AT ZERO TWENTY SEVEN WILL SAVE
LIVES BY ENCOURAGING OTHERS. TO
REGISTER THEIR DONATION WISHES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I AM
VOTE.
SENATOR BREAUX ON THE SIDE OF
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
YOU KNOW I OFTEN TELL A STORY
WHEN I WAS IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY -- THERE WAS A
BILL BEING HEARD THAT THIS THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER IN THE ASSEMBLY
HAD INTRODUCED.
AND THEY HAD A YOUNG MAN COME
AND TESTIFY AND HE TALKED ABOUT
LIFE BEFORE A HEART TRANSPLANT
AND LIFE AFTER A HEART
TRANSPLANT HOW HE IS NOW IN A
FORENSIC PATHOLOGIST.
CLASS AT A UNIVERSITY BUT BEFORE
HE COULD HARDLY TAKE TWO STEPS
WITHOUT WALKING.
IN DURING THAT ENTIRE TESTIMONY
THERE WAS PROBABLY ABOUT SEVENTY
FIVE PEOPLE THAT CAME TO THE
MIKE AND WALKED UP AND SAID I AM
THIS PERSON AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL I'M THIS PERSON AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL LIKE WE HAVE
ALL IN COMMITTEE.
THE VERY LAST PERSON THAT CAME
TO THE MICROPHONE WAS A HISPANIC
MALE HIT ON A TAN TROUSERS AND A
TRêN SHIRT AND HE WAS TWISTING
A TAN HAT IN HIS HAND.
AND HE WALKED UP TO THE MIKE AND
HE SAID I SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE MY SON'S HEART.
LIVES IN EDUARDO.
AND SO I THINK THAT WAS THE MOST
COMPELLING TESTIMONY AND IT'S
ONE OF THE THE THE AND THIS
HEARINGS THAT I WILL ALWAYS
REMEMBER SO I THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
LABEL YOU CAN CLOSE.
THANK YOU TO THE MINORITY LEADER
THAT GAVE ME CHILLS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION OF USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE.
SENIOR NON THE MEASURE PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NEXT UP.
SIR PAN S. YARD.
THIRTY PASS ON FILE.
NEXT SENATOR GALGIANI.
HOUSE ON FILE.
CENTER LEYVA YOU READY I AM
READY S. C. R..
TWENTY FOUR MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA
RELATIVE TO ARTS EDUCATION MONTH.
SOONER OR LATER WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY IS A PROUD AUTHOR OF
S. C. R. TWENTY FOUR WHICH
RECOGNIZES MARCH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AS ARTS EDUCATION MONTH.
ARTS EDUCATION WHICH INCLUDES
DANCE MUSIC THEATER AND THE
VISUAL ARTS IS A CRITICAL LINK
TO STUDENT SUCCESS.
ARTS EDUCATION PROVIDES AN
IMPORTANT WAY FOR STUDENTS TO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES AND A METHOD
OF CREATIVE FREEDOM.
ARTS EDUCATION HELP STUDENTS
DEVELOP CRITICAL THINKING AND
INTERCULTURAL UNDERSTANDING
STUDENTS INVOLVEMENT IN ARTS
EDUCATION ALSO LEADS TO LOWER
DROPOUT RATES AND HIGHER
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE AND
CERTAINLY HELPS TO PREPARE
STUDENTS. FOR SUCCESSFUL FUTURE
MEMBERS I'D URGE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY FOR SCO TWENTY FOUR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEE NO FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM.
MATT AND THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
ALSO FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNITS ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE OF
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEASURE
PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NEXT UP IS
ITEM TWENTY S. C. R. THIRTY FIVE
BY SENATOR RUBIO SENATE RUBY ARE
YOU READY.
PASS ON FILE.
NEXT ITEM SB.
FOUR NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR
DORADO SENATOR DRAWS ARE YOU
READY.
THANK YOU MISTER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR NINETY FIVE BY
SENATOR DORADO AN ACT RELATING
TO CHILD CUSTODY.
SENATOR RUSSELL.
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THE BILL SB.
FOUR NINETY FIVE PROHIBITS THE
COURT.
FROM CONSIDERING THE SEX GENDER
IDENTITY GENDER EXPRESSION OR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OF A PARENT.
LEGAL GUARDIAN OR RELATIVE IN
DETERMINING THE BEST INTEREST OF
A CHILD FOR THE PURPOSE OF
GRANTING CUSTODY.
SO CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW.
UNDER CURRENT CALIFORNIA LAW
CHILD BECAUSE CITY
DETERMINATIONS ARE GOVERNED BY
THE BEST INTEREST STANDARD.
A BEST INTEREST DETERMINATION IS
A HOLISTIC APPROACH.
IT REQUIRES CONSIDERATION OF
THINGS LIKE HEALTH AND THE
SAFETY AND THE WELFARE OF THE
CHILD.
THE NATURE AND THE AMOUNT OF
CONTACT WITH EACH PARENT AND
OTHER RELEVANT FACTORS.
THE SEX GENDER EXPRESSION GENDER
IDENTITY OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION
OF A PARENT.
LEGAL PARENT LEGAL GUARDIAN OR
RELATIVES HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH AN INDIVIDUAL'S ABILITY. TO
LOVE AND CARE FOR THEIR CHILD
THEY SHOULD NOT BE CONSIDERED IN
DETERMINING CUSTODY.
THIS MEASURE IS SPONSORED BY
QUALITY CALIFORNIA THE LONG
BEACH BAR ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FOUNDATION
WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE.
IT IS UNOPPOSED AND RECENTLY
PASSED THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BY A VOTE OF SEVEN TO
ZERO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
SEEN ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
WELL.
I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I ASSUME [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LAW [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I BROUGHT [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I'M BURKE.
I WHITE HOUSE SKI [inaudible]
I WIENER.
I WILK.
HI.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ATKINS [inaudible] FIVE BATES
[inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
GROVE -- TADA [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BROWN [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
STONE.
ICE THIRTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP IS SENATE BILL SIX FOUR
FIVE BY SENATOR MINING DINNER
MONEY ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THIS
ITEM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
[inaudible]
READ.
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY FIVE BY
SENATOR MINING.
AN ACT RELATING TO DEPOSITIONS
DINNER MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS.
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY FIVE
PROTECT DYING VICTIMS WHO SUFFER
FROM STE TO SPECIFIC DISEASES
MESOTHELIOMA AND SILICOSIS FROM
DAYS AND DAYS OF ABUSE OF
DEPOSITION QUESTIONING.
IN CIVIL CASES.
THE BILL LIMITS DEPOSITIONS OF
DYING MESOTHELIOMA AND SILICOSIS
VICTIMS TO SEVEN HOURS IN
ADDITION.
THE COURT IN ITS DISCRETION MAY
GRANT UP TO THREE MORE
DEPOSITION HOURS UPON REQUEST BY
DEFENSE COUNSEL.
IN THE INTEREST OF FAIRNESS AS
LONG AS THE HEALTH OF THE
DEPONENT.
DOES NOT APPEAR IN DANGER BY THE
GRANT OF ADDITIONAL TIME.
UNFORTUNATELY THE COURTS ARE NOT
FOLLOWING THE CURRENT TIME
LIMITS PUT IN PLACE FOR CIVIL
DEPOSITIONS AND INSTEAD --
ALLOWING DYING ASBESTOSIS AND
SILICOSIS VICTIMS TO BE DEPOSED
FOR DAYS AND WEEKS ON END.
FRIENDS MANY OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
OLDER AND WILL DIE QUICKLY DUE
TO THE NATURE OF THE DISEASE.
THIS IS A NARROWLY CRAFTED BILL
AND I ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
TEAM NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
I ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
WELL.
I FOR JUST.
NO BRADFORD.
I COVER ADAM [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
I THEIR OTHER [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
I TADA [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO LEYVA [inaudible]
I MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I MORE LOCK [inaudible]
GIRL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible] FIVE
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
I UMBERG.
I WHAT CASKEY [inaudible]
I WIENER [inaudible]
I WILK [inaudible]
HI.
I'M SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I MORAL [inaudible]
BROWN'S [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
HIGHS THIRTY ONE KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS ITEM TWENTY THREE SB
ONE FORTY THREE BY SENATOR
SCANNER CENTERS CAN ARE YOU
READY FOR THIS ITEM.
YES THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO BUSINESS.
THANK YOU AND MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SB.
ONE FORTY THREE ALLOWS METAL
RECYCLERS TO PAY -- THE
CUSTOMERS THAT COME TO THEM TO
SELL SCRAP METAL.
WITH PREPAID CARDS CURRENTLY THE
LAW -- REQUIRES THAT THEY BE
PAID ONLY WITH CASH OR A CHECK.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS CHANGE IS
THAT IT HELPS TO PREVENT METAL
THEFT.
BEYOND CHECK FRAUD THERE WERE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS BUILT IN SO
THAT THE CARDS WOULD NOT HAVE
EXORBITANT FEES -- THE BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND I ASKED FOR A
VOTE.
JEAN NO FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION OF USING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM.
SENATE HEARING ON THE MASURE
PASSES.
THIRTY EIGHT ZERO NEXT WE MOVED
TO CONSENT CALENDAR IS THERE ANY
ITEM THAT SENATORS ARE LOOKING
TO REMOVE FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEN NUNS MOUNT SECTOR PLEASE
READ CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL [inaudible]
FOR THIRTY NINE OKAY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION USING AN
HONEST ROLL CALL ON THE CONSENT
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
OKAY.
MEASURE PASSES THIRTY SEVEN ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PASSES.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE THERE ANY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
IN A COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
CENTER TOGGLE.
YES WE WILL BE HAVING A A
MEETING AT AFTER SESSION TODAY
FOR HUMAN SERVICES FROM.
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU AT
THREE PM REALLY KNOW IT.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENT. THIRTY NINE WERE
MOVING TO RETURN OU BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS
WOULD BE THE TIME FOR A JOURNEY
MEMORIES.
WE HAVE SEVERAL SO.
SENATOR PORTANTINO ARE YOU READY
FOR YOUR JOURNEY MEMORY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS.
COLLEAGUES TODAY I ADJOURN I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A
GOOD FRIEND OF MINE.
DR VIRGINIA YOU'RE READING --
DOCTOR REBATE DIED LAST SATURDAY
MARCH THIRTIETH AT THE GARDEN
CRESS REHABILITATION CENTER.
IN SILVER LAKE WHERE SHE WAS
RECEIVING HOSPICE CARE.
DOCU REBAY VIRGINIA.
WAS AN EDUCATOR COUNSELOR AND
LGBT YOUTH EDUCATOR OUT REACH
ADVOCATE WHO IS BEST KNOWN FOR
FOUNDING PROJECT.
TEN AN EDUCATIONAL SUPPORT AND
DROP OUT PREVENTION PROGRAM FOR
LGBT YOUTH IN THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
TOGETHER WITH MODELS OF PRIDE
PROJECT TEN IS THE LARGEST FREE.
CONFERENCE. FOR HIGH SCHOOL LGBT
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS IN THE
COUNTRY.
BORN IN LOS ANGELES SHE LIVED
HER ENTIRE LIFE IN PASADENA.
SHE GREW UP IN AN ITALIAN FAMILY
LIVING WITH HER PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS IN THE SAME
HOUSEHOLD.
SHE WENT TO CATHOLIC SCHOOL
THROUGHOUT ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
HIGH SCHOOL AND COLLEGE AS SHE
MOVED TO ADULTHOOD.
SHE FELT THE NEED A CALLING TO
CHOOSE AMONG SOCIAL WORK NURSING
OR TEACHING.
BUT SHE CHOSE TO BECOME A
TEACHER.
DURING HER JOB AS A SCIENCE
TEACHER AND COUNSELOR AT FAIRFAX
HIGH SCHOOL.
GINNY BECAME INTERESTED IN LGBT
YOUTH AND LGBT IF YOU SUPPORT.
THAT'S WHEN SHE FOUND A PROJECT
TEN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR TO
HELP SCHOOLS CURTAIL HARASSMENT.
OF LGBT STUDENTS REDUCING LGBT
DROPOUT RATES AND HELPING LGBT
Q. COMMUNITY STUDENTS COPE AS
THEY CAME OUT AS THEY DEALT WITH
PARENTS AND AS THE YOUNGER
BROTHER.
OF A GAY.
STUDENT BACK IN THE SEVENTIES I
KNOW WHAT HE WENT THROUGH.
ON THE HALLS OF THE CAMPUS THAT
JUST HE AND I ATTENDED AND SO
SHE REACHED OUT TO LGBT STUDENTS
ALL ACROSS LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
PROJECT TENDS MAIN GOAL IS TO
ESTABLISH A VOLUNTARY
CONFIDENTIAL PEER SUPPORT GROUP
LED BY TRAINED FACILITATORS THE
SUPPORT GROUPS PROVIDED A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT FOR DISCUSSING.
THE COMING OUT PROCESS FAMILY
RELATIONSHIPS HARASSMENT AND
HEALTH PROJECT TEN PROVIDED LGBT.
STUDENTS ARE QUESTIONING
STUDENTS A SUPPORT OF SAVE SPACE
TO TALK ABOUT THEIR ISSUES THEIR
LIVES.
THEIR LIVES AND THEIR FUTURE SHE
HELPED THEM LEARN ABOUT
THEMSELVES AND DEVELOP A SENSE
OF EMPOWERMENT AND SELF WORTH.
THE ORGANIZATION ADDITIONALLY
WORKED TO EDUCATE YOUNG PEOPLE
EDUCATORS AND PARENTS ON
IMPORTANT ISSUES SUCH AS HIV
AIDS STDS.
TEENAGE PREGNANCY PREVENTION AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE LAST YEAR I
ATTENDED THE MODELS OF PRIDE
CONFERENCE WHERE I GOT TO TALK
TO PARENTS OF LGBT TEENS AND
SHARE MY PERSONAL FAMILY STORY.
AND IT'S JUST A CONFERENCE IS
JUST A WONDERFUL SUPPORT BOTH
FOR FAMILIES PARENTS STUDENTS.
AND THOUSANDS OF KIDS -- SO MUCH
TO DOCTOR YOUR REBATE SHE LEAVES
BEHIND A PROUD LEGACY OF
FIGHTING FOR THE LGBT COMMUNITY
AND HER WONDERFUL WIFE GAIL
RALPH.
AND I ACTUALLY HAD THE HONOR OF
PERFORMING THEIR WEDDING.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU AND I
KNOW GALA IS HOME WATCHING THIS
ON STREAMING.
IT WAS THE WORST WEDDING
PROPOSAL I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY
LIFE WE WERE AT ANOTHER WEDDING.
AND GALLON GINA ARE LIKE NIGHT
AND DAY ONE IS QUIET CONFIDENCE
IN THE OTHER IS IN YOUR FACE.
AND FULL OF A VINEGAR AS THEY
LIKE TO SAY AND WE'RE SITTING
THERE AT THIS WEDDING WAS
ACTUALLY A TRIPLE WEDDING.
AND IT WAS PRETTY FUN BECAUSE
GAIL SAID GINA.
WE SHOULD GET MARRIED.
ANTHONY SHOULD PERFORM THE
WEDDING.
AND I LEANED OVER AND WHISPERED
INTO GALS HERE I SAID.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO PROPOSE FIRST.
I SAID THAT WAS THE WORST
PROPOSAL I'VE EVER SEEN.
SHE'S A WAIT A MINUTE ENTER TO
GET YOURSELF ON OUT.
LET'S GET A DATE LET'S PICK A
DATE RIGHT NOW AND I SAID GINA
YOU ARE GAIL YOU HAVE AN ASH
GINA YET.
IF SHE'LL SAY YES I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN TOGETHER FOR THIRTY YEARS
BUT YOU DIDN'T ASK HER. FOR SHE
WASN'T EVEN LISTENING TO ME SHE
JUST PULLED OUT OF HER PHONE MY
PHONE WE PICK THE DATE WE
SCHEDULED THE WEDDING.
AND I WAS HONORED TO PERFORM
THEIR WEDDING SO THEIR DEAR
FRIENDS AND AS THEY FOUGHT AS
ANY COUPLE WOULD FIGHT THEY
WOULD OFTEN USE ME BECAUSE I
WON'T SAY WITH THIS EMBRRASSING
TRAIT THAT OF VIRGINIA AND I
SHARED TOGETHER.
SHE WOULD ALWAYS SAY BUT YOU
KNOW OUR SENATOR AGREES WITH ME
ON THAT ISSUE AND SO THEY WOULD
GOOD NATUREDLY FIGHT AND USE ME
AS THE REASON. FOR TO JUSTIFY
THE THEIR THEIR ARGUMENT BUT I
LOVE THEM BOTH AND I'M HONORED
TO STAND AND RISE IN THE JUST
THINK OF ALL THE YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN TOUCHED BY THEIR LIVES
IN LEGACY AND ASK FOR US TO
RESPECTFULLY ADJOURNED IN HER
MEMORY.
THANK YOU.
HERE WE ARE ON THE SIDE OF THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESIDENT -- I ARISES CHAIR OF
THE LEGISLATIVE LGBT CAUCUS TO
JOIN OTHER SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES AND REMEMBER A MYSTERY
BAG WHO -- DID INCREDIBLE WORK
TO SUPPORT ALL TO BE TO YOU --
YOU ARE ELIGIBLE YOUTH ARE AT
SUCH HIGH RISK OF BULLYING OF OF
DEPRESSION OF SUICIDE -- AND
THERE AREN'T ENOUGH PEOPLE
LOOKING OUT FOR THEM -- AND THEY
THEY STAY HEALTHY AND STRONG BY
SUPPORTING EACH OTHER -- THESE
KIDS BUT ALSO BY HAVING ADULTS
WHO WHO ACTUALLY TAKE THE TIME.
TO CARE ABOUT THEM AND TO STAND
UP FOR THEM -- AND TO HELP THEM
BE HEALTHY AND STRONG AND
SUCCESSFUL IN LIFE -- SO -- TO
VIRGINIA YOU READ THAT I WANTED
TO SAY -- WE NEVER MET -- BUT
THE CENTER LOS ANGELES HAS TOLD
ME ABOUT YOU AND REST IN POWER
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CENTER PORTANTINO WE'RE GONNA
ASK THAT YOU BRING IN NAME FOR
IT AND WE CAN PROPERLY MORE
ALLIES MYSTERY BAND THANK YOU.
FOR FOR TRIGGERED STANDING
CONDOLENCES ON BEHALF THE SENATE
SENATOR BORDERS.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
SENATE ADJOURNED TODAY IN MEMORY
OF MY CONSTITUENTS AND LOAN
RESIDENT.
OUR E. ON RESIDENT TO ANDREW --
DREW -- MOCKING.
DREW DIED SUDDENLY ON HIS THIRTY
NINTH BIRTHDAY WHILE THEY KEY
SHOOTING AND FISHING ON THE
ICONIC HUMBLE CHORE WITH HIS
WIFE AND THREE YOUNG CHILDREN.
HIS STRENGTH WAS ENFORCING NO
MATCH FOR THE SNEAKER WAVE THAT
THREW HIM ON THE ROCKS AND INTO
THE SURF.
EVEN THE BRAVERY OF HIS WIFE
BRANDING.
WHO ATTEMPTED TO RESCUE HIM WAS
TO NO AVAIL?
DREW WAS A COMMITTED P. JEANNIE
TROUBLE MAN WHO WORKED
TIRELESSLY NIGHT.
OR DAY TRAVELING IN TRAVERSING
THE MOST HAZARDOUS AREAS OF OUR
STATE TO REPAIR LINES IN RESTORE
ENERGY.
TRULY LEAVES BEHIND A HUGE AN
EXTENDED FAMILY THAT WILL MISS
HIM HIS MOTHER TERRI FATHER
CHALK AND AUNTS AND UNCLES AND
COUSINS.
LOVING COMMUNITY MEMBERS THE SEA
SCOUTS AND P. JEANNIE
BROTHERHOOD WHERE HE'S BEEN A
RESPECTED MEMBER FOR MANY YEARS.
THE ONLY THING THAT DREW WAS
MORE DEDICATED TO THAT HIS JOB
WAS HIS FAMILY.
IT'S TRUE LOVE BRANDY.
IN THEIR THREE BEAUTIFUL
CHILDREN [inaudible]
ATTY.
CYRUS AND RONIN HE WILL BE
MISSED.
THANK YOU SENATOR BORDERS.
PLEASE BRING THE NAME FOR TO CAN
BE PROPERLY MORALIZING EXTENT
SENATE CONDOLENCES SUCH A LOSS.
CENTER ON BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE -- TO REQUEST
THAT WE HONOR AND ADJOURNMENT
THE MEMORY OF LIFELONG RESIDENT
AND FORMER MAYOR AND CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER WELL DONOVAN.
AND HIS WIFE -- THEY WERE
PILLARS OF THE GARDEN GROVE
COMMUNITY.
A WALL WAS BORN ON MARCH SEVENTH.
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX AND WAS A
LIFELONG LARGO RESIDENT WHO WAS
ELECTED STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT
GARDEN GROVE HIGH IN.
NINETEEN FORTY TWO AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL HE PLAYED FOOTBALL AT
SANTANA.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ONE ON THE
UNIVERSITY OF OREGON IN FACT
NEARLY ESTABLISH THE RECORD FOR
MOST TOUCHDOWNS IN HIS FRESHMAN
YEAR IS JUNIOR IF YOU WILL -- IN
THE PACIFIC COAST FOOTBALL
LEAGUE.
AFTER COLLEGE HE RETURNED TO THE
CITY OF GARDEN GROVE AND HE AND
HIS WIFE FOR MEMBERS OF EVERY
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION YOU CAN
IMAGINE THE ROTARY CLUB.
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE ELKS
CLUB THE MASONIC LODGE -- THE
SHRINERS.
HE ALSO HE AND HIS WIFE WERE
ALSO VERY ACTIVE IN THE BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUB HE'S REMEMBER DEARLY
BY HIS WIFE DIANE.
OF SEVENTY ONE YEARS HIS THREE
CHILDREN EIGHT GRANDCHILDREN AND
FIVE GREAT GRANDCHILDREN THANK
YOU AND I ASK YOU JOIN ME IN.
REMEMBERING WALL DONOVAN.
PLEASE BRING THE NAME FOR TO YOU
CAN BE PROBABLY MORALIZING ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE WE EXTEND
OUR CONDOLENCES.
CENTER ON BURKE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT THE I ALSO RISE.
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF SOLEDAD CABRERA
CLASSES SHE IS THE MOTHER OF EVA.
AND VINCE THERMAE UNTIL --
VINCERE MANTO'S A COUNCIL MEMBER
IN SANTA ANA SHE DIED VERY NEAR
HER EIGHTY FOURTH BIRTHDAY AND
ALSO WAS A PILLAR OF HER
COMMUNITY SHE IMMIGRATED FROM
SAN JUAN'S ARCHITECT AS MEXICO
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE AND SETTLED
EAST LOS ANGELES WHERE SHE
RAISED SEVEN CHILDREN.
AND ALSO -- HOSTED ANOTHER
DAUGHTER WHO SHE RAISED AS HER
OWN -- SOLEDAD WAS A
HUMANITARIAN ACTIVE IN THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN MULTIPLE
CHERNOBYL ORGANIZATIONS.
A WONDERFUL GOOD SAMARITAN --
IMMIGRANTS WOULD OFTEN COME TO
HER OF FOR HELP IN FOR OTHER
RESOURCES AND AND INCLUDING
LEARNING ENGLISH SHE WOULD
DIRECT THEM TO OUR SON VINCEWHO
WOULD TEACH THEM ENGLISH -- SO
THAT EVEN START OWN SCHOLARSHIP
FUND TO HELP COLLEGE BOUND
HOPEFUL YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN.
WHO NEED ASSISTANCE TO COVER THE
COST OF HIGHER EDUCATION?
SHE HAD A GREAT LOVE FOR ALL
THOSE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
SHOULD BE MISSED BY HER FAMILY
FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY AND ALL
THAT SHE TOUCHED.
S. THAT WE ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
THANKS CENTER PLEASE BRING THE
NAME FORT SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MORALIZING AGAIN ON THE UP THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE STAND
OUR CONDOLENCES.
SENATOR HER TODDLE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I ASKED WE ADJOURN
TODAY'S MEETING AND MEMORY OF
BETTY YOUNGER.
A NATIVE OF BAKERSFIELD AND A
LONG TIME SUPPORTER FOR
ADVANCING THE ARTS AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT HE WAS BORN ON JUNE
THIRTEENTH NINETEEN THIRTY SHE
IS A GRADUATE OF BAKERSFIELD
HIGH SCHOOL RECEIVED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN FINE ARTS
AND ART HISTORY FROM SAN JOSE
STATE UNIVERSITY.
AND A MASTER'S DEGREE FROM UCLA.
SHE WILL ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED
FOR HER ARTISTIC NATURE GENEROUS
ESSENCE AND GIVING COR.
SHE BELIEVED TO BRING IN ART
ALIVE AND PROVIDING VISUALS FOR
THE COMMUNITY TO ENJOY.
EVEN IF THAT MEANT SIMPLY
DRIVING BY AND SEEN IT ON THE
WAY TO WORK OR SCHOOL.
BETTY WAS MADE TO MILTON YOUNGER
FOR OVER SIXTY YEARS TOGETHER
THEY RAISE THREE GIRLS LISA CC
AND LINDA.
AND TOGETHER THEY HAD FIVE GRAND
CHILDREN.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN A
JOINING IN MEMORY OF FREDDIE
YOUNGER OF BAKERSFIELD.
THANK CENTER TRY PLEASE BRING
THE NAME FOR IT SO SHE COULD BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN A
CANOPY OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE WE EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES.
CENTER WIENER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
COLLEAGUES I RISE WITH GREAT
SADNESS YEAH SO THE SENATE
DURING A MEMORY OF CURRIN WOODS --
PROMINENT SAN FRANCISCO
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE AND VOLUNTEER.
WHO WORKED FOR MORE THAN FORTY
YEARS -- TO PROVIDE A VOICE TO
SAN FRANCISCO'S EASTERN WATER
FRY MISSION BAY NEIGHBORHOODS --
RESIDENT OF SAN FRANCISCO'S
MISSION CREEK HOUSEBOAT
COMMUNITY AND YES WE HAVE
HOUSEHOLDS IN SAN FRANCISCO TO
PRETTY AMAZING -- SHE ATTENDED
GEORGETOWN UNIVERSITY AND WORKED
AS AN INSURANCE ACCOUNT
EXECUTIVE.
I IN THE EARLY EIGHTIES SHE
HELPED CREATE THE MISSION BAY
CONSERVANCY WHICH IS DEDICATED
TO CLEANING OUT MISSION CREEK
WHICH IS BADLY POLLUTED.
AND SINCE THEN SHE WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO ENSURE -- THAT
DEVELOPMENT IN THAT AREA AND
IT'S AN AREA THAT HAS SEEN A LOT
OF CHANGE OVER THE YEARS.
WOULD BE SHAPED -- IN A WAY THAT
WORKS FOR THE COMMUNITY -- SHE
WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING
TO YES AND WORKING WITH
DEVELOPERS WORKING WITH A BROAD
CROSS SECTION OF THE COMMUNITY I
MAKING POSITIVE CHANGE.
AS CHAIRWOMAN OF THE MISSION BAY
CITIZEN ADVISORY COMMITTEE --
CURRIN WAS REGARDED AS A KEY AND
IT SAYS UNBELIEVABLY LEVEL
HEADED VOICE FOR THE COMMUNITY --
DURING THE REDEVELOPMENT OF THE
MISSION BAY AREA.
INCLUDING THE NEW UCSF MEDICAL
CAMPUS AS WELL AS THE SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS BALLPARK.
AND THE UPCOMING GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS ARENA -- SHE WAS JUST A
TREMENDOUS FIGHTER FOR THE
COMMUNITY -- AND A MAJOR OUTSIDE
IN A HUGE LOSS TO OUR CITY ALSO
KARAN REST IN PEACE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HAND AND BRING THE
NAME FOR IT SO SHE CAN BE
PROBABLY MEMORIALIZED ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE
EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE
WOODS FAMILY.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER WILK THE DUST IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY THREE THIRTY PM
TODAY WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE.
AND WE WILL RECONVENE BACK HERE
ON THURSDAY AT NINE AM THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
CENTERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS FOR THE DAY THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME A MOTION
FOR ADJOURNMENT WILL BE MADE
WE'LL SEE YOU ALL ON THURSDAY AT
NINE AM THIS CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS